-Welcome to the show!
-Thank you.
Thank you for finally having me.
-Yes, and I´m sorry it took me
this long to have you,
but I also want to apologize
for something else.
-What´s that?
-Your co-stars,
Lili and Camila, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-They came on the show,
Betty and Veronica,
and I was excited
to talk to them
about some of their co-stars
on the show --
Luke Perry, Molly Ringwald,
big deals to me,
being the age I am.
And we had this exchange,
and you´ll understand
why I owe you an apology.
When you found out
you were working with them,
did those names
mean anything to you?
-Of course.
I mean, everyone -- Yeah.
-They meant -- Yeah, I mean, I
didn´t know who Luke Perry was.
-Okay.
-For me, it was more
like Cole Sprouse.
-Yeah, for us, it was like,
"Cole Sprouse?"
"Suite Life,"
we grew up with that.
-Okay. Now, tell me something
real quick.
Who is Cole Sprouse?
[ Laughter ]
I´m so sorry.
But it would have been slightly
creepy if I knew who you were.
Right?
-Whatever helps you
get to sleep at night.
-But I am so -- I apologize.
-No, please, come on.
-But, you know, I wasn´t
watching a lot of Disney Channel
in my late 20s.
-Still no?
-Still no. Still even less.
But I have a kid now, and so as
long as repeats are happening --
-They´re going to show it
till I´m old and gray.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I guarantee it.
-So I think, like, you know,
five, six years from now,
I´m going to come into the full
bloom of your early work.
-I´ll finally have a bit of
a mustache in five or six years.
And you´ll still be seeing
those episodes.
-So you -- you were somebody
who liked comics.
-Big-time, yeah.
-Worked in a comic book store.
Is that true?
-I did, yeah.
I worked at a comic shop
called Meltdown Comics.
I used to go to Meltdown Comics
all the time on Sunset.
-Yeah, those guys
are killing it.
-I didn´t know you
from Disney Channel.
I knew you as the guy
who sold me comic books.
-Right, right,
how the tables have turned.
Making me feel a little more
in power now.
-There you go.
So, but this is sort of,
obviously,
a re-imagining
of "Archie" comics.
Were you drawn to the idea
of doing it in a different way?
-At first, if I´m being
completely honest, no.
It seemed a little scary to me.
Because when you come
from a comic background,
which I´m sure you get,
you also come from a background
of, like, purity and purism.
-Adhering to the source.
-Right, right.
-When you start to see people
mess with that really nostalgic
property you love,
it can be quite incendiary.
So when I first read it,
I was a little bit wary.
And then I-I did my audition
just like Rod Serling
when I went in.
Because he´s the narrator
in the show.
I read it like Rod Serling.
And I kind of knew from there
it was going to be a little
stranger, a little weirder,
a little more "Twilight Zone."
And I figured, "Okay, you know,
this could be fun.
Let´s give it a shot."
-I heard you had an argument,
though,
about the purity
of Jughead´s dog.
-Right.
-And so this is about
the casting of a physical dog.
You had an issue with one
of the show´s creators.
-Right.
-What was your iss--
What did you think
the dog should be?
-Oh, man. Okay.
Now that you´re calling --
-You´re a very method actor.
You want to work with
the right kind of dog.
-I need the right --
I need to live with the dog
and breathe with the dog.
No, so Jughead´s dog in the
comics is a dog called Hot Dog.
And he´s undoubtedly
the worst part of the digests.
Hands down,
he´s the scariest thing
and adds really not too much.
But for some reason,
I was addicted to the idea
of having an English sheepdog
like he is in the comics.
And he was originally pitched
as, like, a pit bull.
-Oh, so you were very upset
with that.
-And, you know, I thought,
"Okay, well, we got to
try and figure out a way
to get an English sheepdog."
So for a week, a week,
I was trying to wear Roberto
down about this.
And we got this dog.
And this dog was the worst actor
I have ever --
-The sheepdog?
-The sheepdog, yes.
-Yeah.
I grew up with sheepdogs,
and they are lovely creatures
who are dumb as rocks.
-So dumb. So dumb.
-Yeah.
So, yeah, I can´t imagine
any of my dogs
growing up being able to, like,
hit a mark.
-It barks the whole time.
It didn´t hit its mark.
It broke fourth wall
consistently.
-Yeah.
-It was just no good.
-All right. Well, I´m glad
you´re owning up to that.
-I made a mistake.
-All right, good.
Thank you.
You do something that I love.
-Finally.
-You´re very active on Twitter.
-One thing that you love.
-No, no, I love a lot about you.
And, um...
-Go on.
-But this is great.
So you take advantage of --
People post about you and your
twin brother, Dylan, a lot.
And your responses to them,
I have to say,
are really, really funny,
because you are --
-Were these, like,
the news articles?
-Yeah, news articles.
So there´s one, a picture
of your brother that says,
"10 child stars
who are completely broke,"
and then you wrote
to your brother,
"Did you hear the news?"
-Right.
-I really like that.
-And he did.
He did hear the news.
-He did.
This one wrote, "Cole --
I hate wet, sloppy kisses."
And your response to that was,
"I´m also wearing a plaid
train conductor´s hat,
so why are you trusting
my 10-year-old opinion?"
-Geez.
-This is my favorite, though.
-This was a look.
-This is a very -- Because you
see these all the time.
They´re, like, click bait.
This is "32 child stars
who died shockingly young."
A photo of you shockingly alive.
-Right.
-And you wrote, "Dead on
the inside counts, too."
[ Laughter ]
Which is excellent.
It´s excellent.
-Thank you.
[ Applause ]
-But --
-That was my Twitter peak.
-No, I think I´m about --
This, I think, is your
Twitter peak right here.
And I´m going to --
This is a poem that you wrote.
You posted a poem you wrote
to your mom.
But instead of showing,
letting people read it,
I would love for you to read it,
´cause it is --
You wrote -- And you did write,
"I was a psycho baby
before it was hip."
-"I love you, Mom.
You are the best.
You´re better than all the rest.
And if anyone ever
takes us apart,
I´d repeatedly stab them
in the heart."
-Wait.
Look at -- Now look
at the handwriting!
Look how young you were!
[ Laughter ]
That´s fantastic!
Was that very in line
with your thinking back then?
-Right, I just brought
that angst
all the way into "Riverdale."
-Yeah, exactly.
-I´ve been method forever.
-Yeah, here´s what you need
to know about Jughead.
-Right.
-Congrats on the show.
Really lovely to have you here.